hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
my good friend on the internet Michael
Fisher you probably know him now as mr.
mole he started a new YouTube channel
first of all you should check that out
if you haven't already but more
importantly one of his newest videos was
about all of his daily tech like his
daily drivers the stuff he uses on a
daily basis and I don't know if you
remember video responses on YouTube as a
feature before I was killed off you can
kind of think of this video as one of
those so all the stuff in this video is
my daily tech and stuff I use on a daily
basis so first of all I'll start with
the wearable stuff if you've been
watching my videos for a while you've
probably noticed at some point the band
that I have on my left wrist all the
time it's actually not even a piece of
tech it's probably the furthest thing I
have from a piece of tech on this list
but it's a lens bracelet I'll leave a
link to it below is not super special or
anything it doesn't count my steps or
measure heart rate or anything like that
but it does happen to be pretty much the
same exact size as a canon EF lens mount
now I don't wear a SmartWatch that often
but when I do it's probably because I'm
traveling and I'm trying to save battery
life on my smart phone so that helps me
get less screen time when I just check
my notification on my wrist anyway my
SmartWatch of choice on my Android side
is the Moto 360 and on the iOS side it's
the Apple watch now I do realize you can
use the Moto 360 with the iPhone if you
wanted to but it's just not quite the
same using an Android wear SmartWatch
with an iPhone doesn't quite give you
the same experience as the Apple watch
with an iPhone plus the Apple watch has
gotten a lot better for the iPhone
recently so that's still the best option
so Android Android wear iOS Apple watch
now the golden question or the one
that's most frequently asked that I see
in comments sections all the time and we
see like every day on Twitter is smart
phone of choice daily driver smart phone
and that answer changes like all the
time but here's where we're at right now
so I have a couple of SIM cards my main
SIM card the one that everyone has the
phone number of that's the one my
friends have that's an 18 T SIM card and
that's in my main phone and then I have
a secondary SIM card usually also AT&T
but that one will be in whatever phone
I'm testing and if I'm not testing a
phone at the moment then the secondary
SIM will be
in my iphone so the way it works is if
I'm testing a phone and I like it a lot
and I want it to be my daily it'll move
up and it'll get my main SIM card and
then the secondary sim will go back into
my iPhone so right now my main SIM card
is in a1 plus 3 and I of course made a
video about the zone it's a solid $400
Android smartphone with really clean
software great performance and fast
charging that I really like a lot I
switched to it from I believe the galaxy
s7 edge after testing it because I
preferred the one pluses software and I
think before that I was rockin and Nexus
6p with the Android nougat beta back
when it was just an Android n so it's
one plus three right now and the iPhone
6s plus as a secondary now why is the
iPhone keep coming back to the secondary
sim as a default the iPhone tends to be
better with camera related applications
that aren't the camera apps so things
like if you've seen my snapchat story or
if you've seen beams or my Instagram
basically anything that's taken on a
smartphone that didn't happen in the
camera app those apps all tend to work
better in iOS so that's why you'll see
an iPhone in my other pocket my tablet
of choice I don't really have a daily
tablet I don't use a tablet everyday
anymore
sometimes iPad pro sometimes pixel see
but again neither of those things are
used every single day so the batteries
just last forever since it sit around
but my laptop of choice my main laptop
that I do use as a daily workhorse is
the 15-inch MacBook Pro it is fully
maxed out and it's the one that was
painted black by color where it was in
the dope tech customs episode it's been
a few months now with it and people
often ask like how does the paint look
or how does the color work coat look
basically the majority of it still looks
pristine but the only blemishes are like
right on the corners where some of the
paint has I guess either chipped off or
rubbed thin not really sure but
obviously since it's a silver finish the
anodized aluminum underneath you can see
that contrasts pretty clearly I think it
still looks pretty good though it gives
it a bit of character and a lot of
people also ask why a fully loaded
MacBook Pro and it's because I do edit
with this machine on the go so when I
went to Google i/o or when I went to
WWDC I was editing in Final Cut on this
machine and I guess that also explains
the desktop of choice which is the 2013
back pro and wow just saying that out
loud makes you realize how long it's
been since they refresh the Mac Pro this
thing is due for an upgrade obviously
I'm ready for a new one but right now I
am rockin the 8 core trashcan
with 64 gigs of ram the dual D 700
graphics cards and of course Mac OS 10
and Final Cut again and this makes it
the main editing rig other little pieces
of tech that I use on a daily basis that
make my life a little easier
one headphones the audio technica ath
m50 Rd the red and 50s have been my
dailies for a very long time so I use
them for editing and their classics
great price great sound pretty much
can't go wrong but when I want to fly or
when I'm using noise cancelling
headphones
it's the bose qc25 and i still use the
j-bird x2s over the new freedoms for
just like generally walking around
they're awesome Bluetooth earbuds I did
a whole video all about them and they're
still really really good I think there's
an awesome deal on them on Amazon like
right now as I'm recording this video so
I'll link it below the like button if
you want to check it out hopefully it's
still a really low price and you can
scoop up that deal so anyway that's the
main bits of tech that I use on a daily
basis and I guess I'll pass this along
to anyone who's watching what tech do
you use on a daily basis or maybe more
importantly how does the tech you use on
a daily basis make your life better and
if you want to make a video response a
video response feel free to do that too
if you're into it
I'm not tagging anyone obviously but
this is sort of an open invitation yeah
that's pretty much it thanks for
watching I'll talk to you guys the next
one peace